the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns update
video in this video I want to show you
some of the new information that has
been released about the upcoming game of
thorn successor show as of right now
Blood Moon is the working title for the
new show however that name might change
before the first episode is ever handed
in to HBO so far we only have a very
small amount of information to go on
based on some of the early reports we
know that the news show will be set
thousands of years before the events of
Game of Thrones the series will
chronicle the world's descent from the
golden age' heroes into its darkest hour
from the horrifying secrets of Westeros
is history to the true origin of the
White Walkers the mysteries of the east
to the Starks of legend it's not the
story we think we know that basic
overall description of the show was
released a few months ago well thanks to
george RR martin and Entertainment
Weekly we now have some new details
about the show let's go ahead and take a
look at what he said Entertainment
Weekly recently spoke to author an
executive producer george RR martin
about the showrunner jane Goldman's
pilot which is currently filming in
Northern Ireland HBO and Martin have
previously revealed the show takes place
roughly 5,000 years before the events in
Game of Thrones when Westeros was a very
different place it leads up to an epic
confrontation what the White Walkers
known as the long night since some fans
have been concerned that the show
doesn't have Targaryen Zoar dragons we
did ask Martin what are some of the
families and creatures that are around
during this time Martin gave some
intriguing hints about the state of
Westeros during the time and he even
noted a possible new title the first
detail that he revealed is Westeros is
divided into roughly a hundred kingdoms
in the prequel we talk about the Seven
Kingdoms of Westeros there were seven
kingdoms at the time of Aegon's conquest
Martin says but if you go back further
than there are nine kingdoms and twelve
kingdoms and eventually you get back to
where there are a hundred kingdoms
that's the era we're talking about here
the seven kingdoms maintain some degree
of order at least until the war broke
out so it sounds like Westeros could be
even more dangerous and chaotic and
lawless than it is in Game of Thrones
like the Wild West Westeros the second
thing he said was there are Starks and
direwolves the pact survives this should
be obvious given the time period the
Starks were descended from the first men
but in case there was any doubt martin
confirms the fan-favorite family is
around the Starks will definitely be
there he said and while much has been
made about the fact that the prequel
predates dragons that doesn't mean there
won't be other creatures obviously the
White Walkers are here or as they're
called in my books the others and that
will be an aspect of it Martin says
there are things like dire wolves and
mammoths number three there will not be
any Lannisters at least not at first
the show takes place before the rise of
the Lannister family Martin says but
there is another family currently
residing in the future Lannister
homestead the Lannisters aren't there
yet but Casterly Rock is certainly there
it's actually occupied by the castor
lease for whom it's still named after in
the time of Game of Thrones the castor
leaves were supposedly swindled from
their homestead by land the clever who
found it House Lannister though it is
unclear if that tale will be told in the
prequel number four it's an ensemble
HBO's cast breakdown appeared to suggest
that the show might be led by a trio of
female leads Naomi Watts Naomi a key in
Denis Gogh when he was asked about this
Martin said that the prequel like Game
of Thrones is more accurately described
as an ensemble story I hesitate to use
the word lead Martin says as you know
for Game of Thrones we never even
nominated anybody for lead actress or
lead actor until recently it was always
for supporting categories because the
show is such an ensemble I think that
will be true for this show - we don't
have leads so much as a large ensemble
cast number five the show might get a
slightly different title than the one
you're expecting the prequel is still
officially untitled Martin emphasizes in
the past the author has suggested the
title the long night
one behind-the-scenes factor that
complicated this choice is that the
third episode of Game of Thrones Season
eight was also titled the long night
while the long night remains Martin's
preferred title there is another similar
possibility being considered I heard a
suggestion that it could be called the
longest night which is a variant I would
not mind he says that would be pretty
good so as you can see since the new
information is from Georgia or Martin
then we can most likely expect to see it
in the new show now since it's during
the Age of Heroes we could have went
back as far as 8,000 years ago this is
roughly when the legends say that the
long night actually happened but the new
article says the show will take place
roughly 5,000 years ago and it still
might be named after the long night that
could mean the legends within a song of
ice and fire are not exactly accurate
also they say there might not be any
Targaryen Zoar dragons however if this
is happening 5,000 years ago then there
is still a chance we could see some
dragons the rise of Valyria happened
5,000 years ago and that's when the
first dragon eggs were found inside of a
volcano so maybe they're just saying
that so they can surprise us later
it's really hard to say right now but at
least we do know we will see how stark
and Winterfell and since the White
Walkers are there we should see the
Nights Watch in the wildlings as well
since Game of Thrones was so successful
I think we will most likely see a lot of
the same ingredients from the original
show only this one obviously happens
5,000 years earlier than the current
story the actors are already in Northern
Ireland and they have already been
filming scenes so we're well underway in
the production phase of the first
episode hopefully some more information
will continue to get released as they
make the show as always I will keep you
up-to-date with any and all interesting
updates about the successor show anyways
I just wanted to go over what George RR
Martin's said in case any of you did not
notice it the link for the full article
will be down below I want to thank
everyone for stopping by to check out
the video and I also want to thank
everyone for supporting the channel I
hope you all have a great day I'll see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]